[Applause]
dining with dictators that's the focus
of tonight's
[Music]
angle they lined up One By One The
plutocrats Who shelled out $40,000 each
to meet with the autocrat who rules 1.4
billion people with an iron fist now
look closely at these people whose
enthusiastic presence last night speaks
volumes Stanley deal the CEO of Boeing
Larry Fink the ESG Guru of Black Rock
Darius samic who is Honeywell CEO hakon
from broadcom and of course the Apple
CEO Uber liberal Tim Cook now the dinner
guests actually leapt to their feet when
the communist leader was
introduced please rise to greet our
guest of honor his Excellency the
president of the People's Republic of
China chin
P oh I wonder what he was wearing all
right the entire Affair was a huge and
much needed booze for China and for she
they're facing major economic problems
back home after all state television in
China showcased the dinner you can see
Tim Cook if you look closely and other
big wigs there and they were all smiles
during the remarks from their dear
leader this year after the world emerged
from the covid-19
pandemic I have respected met in Beijing
with Dr Haron Kissinger Mr Bill
Gates Senator Chun
Schumer and his Senate
colleagues GE and Governor Gavin
Nome now the billionaires you know
eating their appetizers and so forth but
they probably felt like it was like the
Oscars XI was the celebrity and he was
thanking the academy but his audience
back home got the real message China
came out the winner here x was playing
three-dimensional chess and these men in
the audience were China's captured
ponds the funny thing is though many of
those who arrived in San Francisco in
their private jets are the same ones who
make pointless climate change pledges
because they see themselves as cultural
influencers I'm telling you from from
our heart we believe in treating
everyone with dignity and respect and
that's how we show up as a company we
believe in being a part of the community
and trying to advocate for
change does that really does that really
get bought by anyone out they're trying
to advocate for change is that what Tim
Cook said really how do the 2 million
weager Muslims and their X approved
internment camps advocate for change Tim
and how much dignity and how much
respect did the persecuted Christians
get in China
Tim and of course the great irony is
that black rocks Larry Fink among the
worst X bootlickers was the
sanctimonious Force as I said behind the
idea of shaming companies under these
environmental social and governance
standards ESG standards that have
plagued Corporate America in between the
appetizer and the main course did think
press G about clima climate change in
China or the ESG scores and the
state-owned companies
there since World War II I think this
dinner with the dictator and all that's
going to follow is one of the low points
of American capitalism a Communist
Regime that's been endlessly belligerent
toward toward the United States and our
values and viciously repressive toward
its own people emerges stronger and more
influential well and as for us what do
we get we got an unenforceable and vague
pledge about fentanyl chemicals and drum
roll
please we got some more pandas yeah they
promised some pandas what a bargain
remember we don't even own them we just
lease them and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else